debating whether to play with sullivan
or stafford
let's play with sullivan
most certainly have not played this
against a leader of iceland so far
[Music]
okay so
i can't play with sullivan
but there's another variation
called the squirrel
which starts with knight f4
which is kind of hilarious
and my knight's a squirrel because it's
going to be chased around but squirrels
are very good at surviving
and now
i could even play g5
now let's play this
it's been a while since i've studied
squirrel theory
the squirrel is actually one of the
openings on my list
next to the coca-cola and medusa
i don't think it's a good opening but
it's very squirrely
so now this pond's a little bit tender
because i'm chiseling away
don't mess with my squirrel
actually take the knight or the bishop
i'll take the knight
wow
[Music]
don't hurt me
do they have squirrels in iceland
i play this move
this move
oh icelandic oh i signed noob in the
chat says no we have foxes
uh that's kind of disappointing
oh maybe they used to have squirrels but
then probably the foxes ate all the
squirrels
what to do
okay
now now i feel like a hibernating
squirrel
all my pieces on the back rank
but now the squirrel
the squirrel has come out of hibernation
it's springtime
[Music]
it's time to eat all the nuts that i
buried
yeah don't mess with my squirrel
yeah the buried berries
actually i'm pretty sure squirrels are
like
they're really into hazelnuts if i'm not
mistaken
i want to feed and kill this bishop
oh good try trying to trigger the tcs
um
yeah now i feel like a very satisfied
squirrel
but if there's more nuts to eat yes i
can't help myself
oh no my pawn
okay
going for the kill
[Music]
i feel like i've i've weaponized the
squirrel
it's turned into like a
a terminator squirrel or something
[Music]
wait i just mismade in one i'm
getting too lost in the analogies
that's okay though setting up for the
queen sack
oh no my queen
oh yes my squirrel
good game
mr iceland
so yeah i i wasn't lying lee chess calls
us the squirrel
[Music]
and it starts
yeah it starts after knight f4
it's not a good opening
but again it's very squirrely
yeah computer just wants to chase around
the squirrel
like a small puppy